based upon the proposal from the
competition committee sean they may
because the fix and only the nfl's
competition committee can do this peter
there's a problem there's a controversy
all right we have to fix it how do we
fix it let's implement something that
would have made a damn bit of difference
if it had been in place in the first
place that's what the competition
committee essentially has proposed
expansion of replay review
to cover fouls for pass interference
unnecessary roughness with a hit on the
defense's receiver or roughing the
passer it doesn't cover non-calls which
means it would have been meaningless if
it was in place for the nfc championship
game you can't make this stuff up how
could they get it so wrong peter how can
it be with sean payton on the
competition committee that he didn't go
robert de niro in the untouchables and
show up with a baseball bat to the
competition committee meeting until he
got what he wanted what's going on here
usually mike and we talked about this a
little bit earlier
that
and i am in no way defending this
because i agree with you if you create a
rule
in response to possibly
the wrong team going to the super bowl
that doesn't address
why the wrong team may have gone to the
super bowl why are you doing it it's
ridiculous
and and mike you know the only thing
that i can say and let's get out to
arizona and find out i'll just tell you
this mike
you'll have an interesting show on
monday
okay i can i'll predict that right now
because
you and i are going to be in the lobby
of the arizona biltmore hotel
maybe saturday night sunday walking
around finding people and saying okay
excuse me what's the real story what
happened tell us so i think we're gonna
know more about what the real story is
on monday morning
when they go in and start deliberating
this in advance of a possible wednesday
vote
yeah and and there has to be something
more than fear of unintended
consequences because that's what we've
heard all along rich mckay was on with
us at the super bowl and look i i don't
buy this i think they use unintended
consequences as a way to get around
doing things they don't want to do
because they're the ones who are in
position to spot the consequences that
may be unintended and plan for them the
sky judge idea peter i think is a
perfect way to prevent situations like
this the aaf is using it i think the nfl
should at least experiment with it if
you're going to expand replay review
allow it to be available for non-calls
as well i don't know whether it's going
to result in more flags being thrown i
could see that happen because you know
you have this can i tell you about can i
tell you about the sky judge mike mike
i'm going to tell you about the sky
judge okay
as we see a replay of the call we've
seen a thousand times
but but here's the sky judge problem
okay the way the nfl looks at it to get
the sky judge ready for this season a
different way of officiating football
okay is a lot of off-season work
and and and so you know are they ready
to do it not to mention the fact that
there are 17 crews in the nfl so you
have to find
17 men to do this job this sky judge job
that's never been done before and do it
at mid-season level by labor day weekend
uh
it's first of all it's going to be very
hard but second of all
one of the things that i believe the nfl
has the biggest problem with with the
sky judge is that because there aren't
enough existing people to be sky judges
what they may have to do is dip into
their minor league system you know go to
the pac-12 and get the best back judge
bring him up to be a back judge in the
nfl and take one of the best back judges
in the nfl and make him a sky judge in
other words those 17 sky judges that
they would need they would need to take
some of them from existing officials on
cruise so would lessen the quality of
the on-field cruise right now so i agree
the sky judge is a very interesting
concept but there are some unintended
consequences with the sky judge that if
you take some of your best officials off
the field to be sky judges does that
make officiating worse anyway peter
peter it's i got an easy fix for you
think about the referees who have
retired in recent years and haven't gone
on to work in tv do you really want jeff
triplett to be a sky judge do you want
jeff triplett to be a sky judge do you
want jeff trump he's working for us
he's occupied
do you want jeff triplett to have
control of a game at the end of a game
we've seen that movie mike
peter here's the thing though and you
made this point earlier the commissioner
has i think a vested interest in getting
this fixed because look the next time
this happens and i've been saying this
for the last two months and i don't
think anybody is taking this seriously
but they should the next time something
like this happens and there is more
legalized gambling than there currently
is at some point you reach a critical
mass where congress says hey roger
goodell
you're coming to see us we're going to
have a committee meeting a committee
meeting and you're going to sit there in
the michael cohen's seat and we're going
to ask you question after question to
find out why in the hell you haven't
used your billions of dollars in
resources to enhance officiating to
ensure that when hard-working americans
spend their hard-earned dollars on
legitimate wagers that they're not
getting legitimate outcomes to their
games and i just i think that it is
smart for the nfl
to take care of their business before
the the congress starts sniffing around
in their business
i mean i guess so
you're more of a legal slash conspiracy
gambling theorists than i am that's not
but that's not a conspiracy theory
that's that's out in the open they did
it with concussions and they will
eventually do it with gambling
it's possible it's it's it's possible
i'm not saying that it isn't
but
but i i the nfl is or isn't it the nfl
is not making decisions based on the
fact that they believe that there is a
danger of roger goodell being hauled
before congress to justify the they
should whether officiating is any good
maybe they should but i i mean
i think you know you know what you're
very good at you're very good at seeing
a half mile down the road
in this case you're looking 68 miles
down the road and i think you're
inventing something that isn't there
peter i think what the nfl needs to be
concerned about if they don't improve
their officiating and they don't ensure
that they get these calls right as
people are betting their own money
legally on these games and on the
outcomes of these games what the nfl
needs to fear is the creation of a
federal agency that would have oversight
over the nfl over major league baseball
over the nba all these sports leagues
have a common vested interest in taking
care of their own business before the
nfl creates an sec not southeastern
conference securities and exchange
commission style of agency because look
gam
trading stocks is gambling and there are
layers and layers of regulatory
protections for the average american and
this same thing is going to happen it's
a no-brainer look at which way the wind
is currently blowing in washington it
isn't going to take many elections to
get to the point where you have a very
active congress that is over regulating
business and the nfl needs to be
concerned about and that's the end cat
look over regulating business are you
crazy are you watching boeing right now
are you watching saying it's going to
so
but but hey mike mike has adam silver
sat in front of congress to talk about
tim donahey
no he hasn't no i mean because gambling
wasn't legal then
okay but okay so gambling is legal now
and so why is the uh why is it the nba
there's 48 calls every night in the nba
where you say why wasn't that called the
nba is not the nfl this does not rise
this does not rise to the level of
congress looking at it in any way shape
or form it will it will and here's the
thing peter here's here's my ultimate
and i don't know that this is a
conspiracy theory this is just cynicism
run amok i don't think roger goodell
cares i think he's rolling the dice on
by the time that happens well he's not
going to be in office by then
yeah i mean come on so after the next
after the next
after the next cba he's gone anyway so
remember that you've seen that hey mike
mike
and you have seen let me just
make this point you have seen this in
the last year the great disappearing act
of roger goodell
you know he used to be a pr uh you know
a uh a flesh presser you know he used to
be hey how's everybody doing what's
going on roger goodell has disappeared
from the face of the earth
you know and i think it's roger goodell
basically saying i'm going to do this
contract then i'm going to stop being on
the front page of the new york post
38 times a year as a dunce
and you guys can go find somebody else
to be a dunce uh and and i'll be out of
here uh because really there's no other
reason why roger goodell has disappeared
from almost all public view
in the last year and it's because he's
just tired of getting the crap beat out
of him and so you know to me this is
i mean i just look at this three four
years down the road and john doe is
going to be the new commissioner of the
nfl i agree with you completely peter
and it reminds me of when paul tagliabue
was on his way out the door they
negotiated a very union-friendly cba
because i think tagliboo just wanted to
get it done and move on and then the
next thing you know you have a lockout
five years later i think that once roger
goodell decides i'm a short timer and
i'm just going to take care of these
last couple of projects get a new tv
deal in place get a new labor deal in
place i'm out of here the next
commissioner can deal with the impact of
legalized gambling on a widespread basis
and what it may mean for us for congress
for american citizens and for everyone
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports